so you both have numerous credits that
span many years in those years of the
career were there times where you said
you know I think I'm done with this I
don't want to do another project or was
it one project into the next group and
say is this really the life I know I am
there were one there was one particular
time that that I was just in fact I was
gonna quit writing I did for a year and
I thought I'm gonna do something totally
different I applied to law school and I
just I was gonna live in DC of all
places and I mean I like I liken it to a
nervous breakdown my nervous breakdown
was applying to law school it's like the
worst thing in the world I ever could
have done and I I did it I mean I did it
I got in I was gonna go and then like a
miracle happened and I mean not that
anybody knew that they were saving me
but then Jerry Bruckheimer saved me by
hiring for coyote ugly and I was just so
I'd worked in bars my whole life so it
made sense and then I got the bug again
and that's when I and then that's my big
big time of wanting to quit and then
there's like a moment in every day where
I go this is insane but then I get over
that well for me it's a daily process
every morning I hear that I just I can't
do this anymore isn't that kind of and
then I get up and I and suddenly I'm
like I want to make this film I want to
make another film I you know till I die
I want to make films and I just love
cinema and I've always loved making
films and so it's a constant process you
know when you have to just you know
shake it up and just make it happen you
know but there have been so many ups and
downs you wouldn't believe it I mean but
you know and I think that's life
and I think you know actually when I
learned actually was when we met Mother
Teresa
in Calcutta she said you know
it's not important how much you do it's
how much love you put into the doing you
know and I think that sort of the the
the feeling that I try to basically live
by you know that even if I don't get the
chance to make all these movies that
I've always wanted to make even if I can
just make another one and give it
everything I have you know that's what
it hopefully will count in the end what
would you say to someone that has had
one very successful project work and
they feel a little bit jaded by the
business they don't realize how much of
a business it is and how little
sometimes some things have to do about
art and you know what do we mean you're
kind of spoiled no I think maybe they've
been disillusioned by what filmmaking or
acting or producing maybe they're not
they're surprised at how much of it has
how little control they probably have
over their vision once bigger names are
attached and they one or a group and
they're on the fence this is something
they never thought they'd get to a
certain level here they've gotten to
that level and now they're questioning
do I really want to do this it took so
much effort to get to this point which
so many people look at from afar and say
wow that's amazing I want to be in your
shoes but they're not sure do they want
to continue so what advice to that oh
that's a good question the I met
somebody the very first month that I
came to LA and and I didn't know that I
wanted to do film so I was a playwright
and I came to the play and I met a young
producer who now is a big big deal want
Gordon brilliant guy and he said to me I
was like oh my god do I want to do film
blah blah and he said you know this
business he goes you have to ask
yourself can you handle something
terrible happening to you once a year
and then something horrible happening
everyday and otherwise you can't live
with it because it's a very it's a very
tough business and you have to it's like
I feel when I when people say to me oh I
want to write a book or I want to write
you know I'm like it shouldn't be about
you want to you need to
if you don't need to like what Raphael
just said he needs to so it sounds like
it boils down to you've got to need to
do it but yeah you were almost about to
go to law school you were probably
getting paperwork ready and then you get
this call or whatever it was my agent
then Martin Spencer you know I was in
Paris kind of um hanging with a
girlfriend you know my last two Rob
before I buckled down and make something
of myself you know and go beat I thought
I'd be like a child ad potato or
something you know I wasn't gonna go be
a corporate lawyer but still it doesn't
anybody that knows me knows I'm not
academic I didn't do well in school it's
a miracle I got in it made no sense it
was running away from myself in a way
and then when my and you know my agent
faxed me this article because the writer
was a bartender at coyote ugly and she'd
written this great article in Esquire
that Jerry had optioned and I was like
oh my god it's my life because it was
not that I'm a singer what she was but
the idea of working at a bar and the
life and and then you know I kind of
like had to admit okay that's my
authentic self to do that and I'm going
back in you know because you know
everything else in life there are grades
it's like well if you pass that test
you're gonna get an A and then you're
gonna get this reward and then you're
gonna get that reward in this business
you can get rewarded for failing and you
can get passed over for succeeding and
it's just very like I mean many many
people I know never ever get a movie
made but they but they are politically
slav they write scripts that are fun to
read even if they're not filmic
necessarily and then there's other
people that are terrific right you know
great writers I know that don't have the
social skills in a room you know because
it is entertainment and if you're going
to pitch you know you don't want to bore
the person that's gonna write the check
you know because it's hard to translate
that some
writers are by nature loners and so it's
not really fair to expect them to do you
know a circus act in the room but people
are people and they don't want to be
bored
you